um uh oh my god sorry about my attitude
guys um I had a nap but when I have a
nap they get grumpy and I came in here
and I threw some [ __ ] heat down you
know what it is that you know last week
the welcome to tiger belly I read on
Twitter you know about you know that
somebody like on Twitter said this is no
less a list of the best podcast or
whatever whatever and like I guess bill
Perez wasn't on the list some some guy
commented you know I mean like how the
[ __ ] biz but bill burr not on this list
and Bobby Lee's podcast is he's he goes
he's he he does only Asian jokes and
then he also tries to be alpha male with
all the people that work there that's
what he said it goes to show he
absolutely does not listen to this
podcast no he I guess no but I know what
he's saying he's saying like I'm you
know you know how I be yella roast roast
and roast beta move em I understand that
but the guy I wanted the guy that if the
guys listening right now I want to tell
him that I didn't make the list and if
there was a list I wouldn't put my name
above any ones now I don't give a [ __ ]
you're right I do I think that Bill burr
should be in every list I think she'd
been the number one list right but I
just want to say this to the guy is is
that you know you could have say
whatever you want to [ __ ] say but
everyone on that list everyone on that
list they're all my friends and they
think that I'm legit you go to any of
those guys Tom Segura Joe rubber and
that what do you think of Bobby Lee
right and they weren't gonna go uh I
shouldn't be on any list right so it's
like when I read that it hurt my
feelings for a second but then I had to
think it through and go [ __ ] yourself
bro because that's ridiculous
Phoenix we're we're on the list I don't
know what do what are you trying to do I
want to know where we are we made a list
I'm happy no it was it was like he was
just yeah these are my favorite and it's
just like and then they tried it and
then they're guys that think that I'm
not fine it's fine
anything I should be on the [ __ ]
fine but then it's like then they throw
their little opinions in there's fine
it's America right but at the end of the
day it's like you know you try to hurt
me bro
I don't did nothing to you right and
then all of a sudden I have to just say
something happy yeah you know I just
think I'll get them made
[Music]